[Musik]
ruhig 470 millionen euro
hi
hab ich da hinten ja gar nicht gesehen
bis ich hab mir wirklich zu tun gerade
meiner kunden al arisch den so viele
kunden gerade überall am start aber ich
hab mir gedacht ja auch wenn ich so ein
toller weltbekannter künstler bin mache
ich heute mal trotzdem ein video und war
auf der website foto generator punkten
trug laut punkt nl an der stelle große
schau die der hat das gestern
hochgeladen deswegen habe ich auch in
der beschreibung verbandsversammlung hat
mir gedacht ich als luca picasso muss
natürlich auch zu schlagen der wegen
meine damen und herren habe ich mir
bilder von den betten youtube
deutschland deutschland der welt den
letzten juni war ausgesucht und direkt
an mit dem er sich habe in organischer
worum es geht
auf dieser website sehen wir links einen
input feld und rechts an autos fällt und
das was wir quasi hier zeichnen jetzt
hier dann als echtes bild dargestellt
ja revidiert um zum thema zurückzukommen
sagt mirja von invest in youtube an der
welt rausgesucht und aber die sagen
vermehren kann mit meinem kaputten die
institute zwar kanada
l
ja
ich zeichne den x ich habe euch recht
bei aufpoliert erstmal das bild von mir
eingebildet also ich hab das jetzt
einfach mal von hilfswerk haben genommen
hat jetzt ein bisschen nach bezeichnen
das war der halt jetzt kommt hier so die
lederjacken also der halten fällt mir
noch nicht gewohnt hier wieder nach oben
und dann ist hier wieder die lederjacke
die hier ansetzt ihr kern als verschluss
der sohn beziehung oft aber und dann
hier auf der rechten seite haben wir
dann noch die haben nur durch eine
handlung knopf entwickeln das ganz
normal
die immer noch bestehenden strecke noch
ein bisschen höher und dann haben wir
ihr die haare kommen da sieht man schon
auf jeden fall dass ich in super
künstlerin kopf ist hier leicht
abgerundeten weil hier oben natürlich
jahre anfangen haben natürlich noch an
den seiten leicht vorhandenen jahren ein
bisschen weniger machen händlern kommen
jetzt mal zu den augen und meine augen
oder andere auge ist so hier sind
natürlich spielen drinnen name hier
diese komische ohrmuschel meine nase
irgendwie so mit den beiden löchern hier
unten und was ist das denn an duran
duran die nagel welche sind eher weiter
hunden den grund habe ich vermisst
hätte
ich weiß warum ich in kunst
offen sei
und der kopf ist natürlich auch hier vom
hals abgetrennt das hier ist das andere
orte barbara hof milliarden hallo ich
bin ich im wieder fällt gerade damen und
herren ich würde sagen ich bin jetzt
dafür hier recht einfach mal aus das
heißt wir haben jetzt nämlich den pc
kroaten und weil ihre rein abhör verdi
drauf drückt mir angezeigt wie meine
unfassbar tolle zeichnung hier in echt
aussehen wird freuen ich würde sagen da
müssen wir wirklich mal ganz kurz
countdown einfügen und zwar wollten 43 2
das sind auf jeden fall hundertprozentig
ist jetzt im vergleich eingeblendet link
verdreckte bild recht das bild was bei
rausgekommen
ich finde das ist auf jeden fall sehr
sehr ähnlich aber wir kriegen hier mal
eben auch hier sehen sie mitarbeitet ist
weit und als nächsten hit überzeichnen
wir nämlich in scope
da kann man sich doch nur verliebt in
diesen blick oder andere fangen wieder
an mit denen häufigeren sachen adressen
soll sein gesicht sein hier fängt die
schulter eine maskuline schulter da hier
oben ist der kopf runter hier von den
zinsen wieder runter und wieder eine
maskuline scholl dateien gesichtes
dickerhof erbitten abgetrennt mit dem
kind das heißt sowie zwecke aus hiphop
am start was eine maskuline schulter ja
abdeckt warum sage ich die ganze zeit
maskuline schulter auf dieser seite hier
auch noch perfekter pass von rom gerät
ihren die kette und freunde wir
natürlich hätte ich meine sind im
youtube-kanal etikette gerade in seinen
hals hätte muss natürlich hinten lang
hier hinten die ohrmuscheln kommt sind
die haare bin
[Musik]
jodi bieber wirklich gut getroffen hier
fallen die haare von hinten ins gesicht
rein hier oben sind die ergo und hier an
der reihe macht einfach weil das ist ein
bisschen wacklig angeordnete dann haben
wir hier einmal eine augenbraue diesen
relativ weit runter geht und diese hier
diese bieten über das gesicht genau auge
hier hat er nämlich offen wo er mich
anruft und das rechte auge hat er
geschlossen so ein bisschen zwinkert
hier ist der großen nase
was das denn luca wir haben wir die nase
mit dem rasen noch die untaten noch ihr
hier und haben den mund der einigermaßen
offen mit bekommt nämlich die zunge raus
das heißt dann aus dem mund walter das
sieht sogar recht gut gelungen aus der 4
x ich noch mal hin von witten an damit
die website einfach erkennt okay da es
wird nicht einfach nur schlecht sondern
es hat wirklich gegen das kultur
irgendeine farbe dahinter hier noch ein
bisschen fahrt auf jeden fall vorhanden
lippe mal ich auch mal konnten an und
ich finde das ist sehr gut gelungen ich
mache hier oben nochmal diese runzlige
stirn
meine damen und herren ich würde sagen
das hier ist auf jeden fall ins komitee
schon auf der rechten seite gerade wir
jetzt nicht mehr eingeblendet arbeitman
der countdown findet wieder statt werden
4 3 2 1
ich klicke auf rot
ich packe euch mal wieder jetzt auf die
linke seite das echte fotos liegen würde
ich sagen
auf jeden fall ja
youtuber habe ich mich auch jemand aus
zudem schaue ich einfach hoch was keiner
seit content angeht was aussagen angeht
ja teilweise in einem video und bringt
einfach was alles mögliche angeht und
patrick j 11 meine damen und herren da
kann man da kann man schon mal applaus
entgegen bringen also ja wir fangen
wieder an hier an der seite ist sein
hemd vielleicht auch klappte dann kommen
wir hier zum august fängt das gesicht an
auf der linken seite dann hier noch ein
ohr dass die haare so ein bisschen so
leicht zur seite gehen die das gewicht
beim bisschen zu sein
andere halten und hier wieder dass ein
bisschen der mund ist relativ weit offen
und die zähne sind dicker so mache ich
jetzt mal dass ich will einfach nur
sehen ob wir jetzt ein paar zähne hier
wirklich anstatt kriegen die
bezeichnungen die keine beleidigungen
youtuber sein also youtuber sind ja oft
an mich gestellt mich schlecht da da
würde ich jetzt ein video gegenüber alle
die hübschesten menschen der welt aber
guckt euch das an also das glaube ich
wie schlecht ich mich mal kann nase hier
noch ebenso meine damen und herren und
wir sehen schon ein wenig beschissener
picasso fried mir mal jetzt in die
kommentare
wenn ihr wollt dass ich mal wieder mit
meinem zeichen tablet youtuber nach
malle dass er früher relativ häufig
gemacht dass ich mir instagram bilder
von youtube angenommen habe und reichen
tablet das ist aber auch schon zwei
jahre her die serie und dann habe ich
einfach die bilder die youtube auch im
hofladen habe haben nachgezeichneten
photoshop danach unsere bild entfernt
und dann hatte ich das was wie ich das
nachgezeichnet habe also ja schreibt
photoshop ihr die kopfhaare pro minute
zu einem nächsten youtuber den ich auch
wieder zeichnen werde und zwar genauso
wie bei patrick auch eine person die
nicht ihren content bewunderte ihre
musik und da habe ich mir einfach
gedacht mit so einem youtube-video nicht
fehlen es ist niemand geringeres als wie
bianca beauty placement ist youtube
man kann hier aber so schöne formen
zeichnen und war hat jetzt nicht gegen
die haare die weitab stehen oder so wie
bei mir so habe die so in alle
richtungen gehen total bescheuert oder
man kann hier wirklich ein sondern
zeichnen und das dir sieht gerade aus
wie ein kleiner penis da haben wir auch
schon bianca fertig ein leute auf jeden
fall spaß beiseite ich glaube jeder weiß
dass hier von mir alles nur ein klub
gemeinde also hier die haare aller
seiten klar
mit jener von beziehungs oder machen
jedoch die augenbrauen hat die relativ
weit hochgezogen das heißt ich zeichne
die man einfach so die augen so alt
werde ich ein bisschen erstaunt das ist
das foto wo sie glaube ich diesen kuchen
kriegten für ihren tollen form bilden
hier rein und ja auch nicht so viele
rein
die nase wieder aus dem hut die partie
denn den mund alter
aber bringt die brille auf weil ich
künstler bin auch die fallschirm auf
machen wir weiter mit dem
machen wir weiter mit dem mund meine
damen er hat den mund legen wifo am
freitag wird er ihre lippe irgendwie der
mund auf jeden fall aus klappt man hat
also das hier ist alles anders dann hat
sie auch schon gewesen sein als ich die
man eben ihren ihr gesicht so ein
bisschen als wenn ich jetzt das wild von
bibi aus und jetzt gehen wir mal wenn
ich auch blicke das
die ähnlichkeit ist verblüffend wie auf
der linken noch mal auf echte bild vom
baby eingeblendet also ich muss wirklich
sagen das ist wirklich also wenn mir das
so einer zeigen würde also ich für
dieses bild jedoch die tatsächlich aus
wie kunst ehrlich gesagt von mir nun für
einige übte der meiner meinung nach
wirklich komplett beteuerten konnte man
sich auf jeden fall dass er da überhaupt
nicht lange dran sind die videos haben
keine struktur keine konzepte noch nie
preis dafür geworben julien
sogar der haarpracht von julie muss man
wirklich sagen das ist kein mensch mit
haaren dass ich fahre mit so ein
bisschen mensch drin auf jeden fall
gehen hier die haare runter und an die
arbeit gehen die haare wieder hierüber
machen wir immer so ein bisschen da die
hna regieren die richtung gerade sie
tatsächlich ein bisschen aus wie nemo
wir die nase die hosen sitzen haus nicht
mit dem nagel noch ihr kleines augen hin
kommentierten auge her natürlich in die
berechnung kompliziert
meine damen und herren da muss ich noch
meine brille hier eben gerade aufsetzen
das hilft auf jeden fall das bild was
wir trainiert haben sich auf der rechten
seite wieder julien eingeblendet
allerdings mit julien jetzt ausgewertet
meiner damaligen countdown 43 weinheim
2,4 2,3 3,9 40.000 wir klicken auf
protest meine damen und herren das
letzte mittel
diese sind alle leute die nach effekt an
der stelle berichtet video setzt
allerdings auch beende meine damen und
herren wenn solch gefallen natürlich auf
jeden fall über nike freunde können
meine bilder online kaufen auf der
website findet miley ein gemälde wir
darauf könnte man kann kostenlos
abonnieren
selbst martin luther king hat früher in
seiner rede gesagt dass man dadurch an
petra mensch wird finden die außerdem
ein stoff eingeblendet wie ich schon
gesagt könnte dort meine zahlreichen
kunstwerke des kapitals zu kopf und wir
unten
ein weiteres video verlinkt
ja